at a global scale both the ecological
and the economic dimensions of the
opportunity are easy to to gauge because
tropical forests do store a fourth of
all terrestrial carbon something like
550 gigatonnes out of the 2,000
gigatonnes that we have tropical forests
are also already a mitigation engine
they are already capturing something
like fifteen percent of our total carbon
dioxide emissions and thirdly of course
tropical forests are considered are
described as a source of emissions of
course the fact is it's our activity is
the land-use change and the degradation
that is going on that is the real source
of emissions but measured in in that way
tropical forests are something like 14
odd percent of the total emissions total
man-made emissions there was a study
done a few years back called the alias
review and they'd made an estimate of
the economic benefits of having the rate
of deforestation out to 2020 and their
estimate was that the present value of
policy actions which led to that having
would be of the order of 4 trillion
dollars in present value terms so
ecologically significant economically
sizable I think at a global scale you
can always conveniently make the
argument but the problem is what happens
on a local scale because when we take it
away from the global scale and I'm
skipping past for a reason the national
m and the provision provincial scales
when you bring it to the local scales
what you face is local communities their
forest dwellers their forest dependence
this is their life this is their home
and you're describing and just deciding
about what you want to do with their
lives and homes it's also about looking
at it from perspectives other than
carbon because the forest is not just
sticks of carbon it's about recognizing
that apart from the mitigation of
climate you also have biodiversity
benefits you also have fresh water
benefits you also have community
livelihood benefits which accrue in
terms of non-timber forest products and
in terms of just the sheer being of
these communities in and around forest
areas and fundamentally what we have to
recognize when we are looking at this is
that we are dealing with basically the
beginnings of a terrestrial carbon
market
and even though we came to it from the
point of view of UNF Triple C and a
whole host of negotiations and we came
to a trauma litigation perspective
reality is that in order to move forward
in a way that works we'd have to think
beyond just forests and beyond just
carbon so now we have broke breaking
this out into to further dimensions it's
not only forest it's about all kinds of
landscapes that are in and around the
forest it's not only carbon but it's all
of the other ecosystem services so it's
that kind of three-dimensional framework
that you must you must keep in mind when
you approach red plus
you